d'abord il faut pas deux il faut pas
d'avoir deux formules globalisante et
blessantes si on est dans la course et
si on est là un concorde nationale il
faut faire attention à ces mots auraient
et il y à des situations qu'il faut
traiter mais on ne peut pas généraliser
je pense que les hommes politiques dans
le moment présent
j'y reviendrai dans nos missions doivent
être économes de leurs maux ils doivent
être capables de maîtriser les choses
car le moindre la moindre formule peut
être pris comme une stigmatisation et
permettre les solidarités contre la
france alors prenons deux exemples parce
que c'était dans votre propre parti
celui de bruno le roux par exemple qui a
été quand même assez vilipendé par
rapport à ses propos est ce aussi d'un
ministre michel sapin qui a dit somme
tout dit que les belges auraient pu être
naïf
même s'il est revenu après sur ses
propos tout cela ne sait ce que vous
dites aujourd'hui c'est ce que je dis
être économe de ses propos ils se sont
tous les deux excusés et ils ont eu
raison
aujourd'hui il faut comprendre que dans
cette guerre il y à la guerre des signes
il y à garder mots il y a une une
entreprise qui vise encore une fois à
séparer les populations il ne faut pas
prêter le flanc à la stratégie déployée
par dash et le temps ils se sont trompés
même s'ils seront ils en sont revenus
sur leurs propos je vais pas les
commenter mais je dirais pour tout le
monde
il faut faire attention aujourd'hui à ce
que l'on dit